Okay, this section will wrap up this course with a few more final recommendations, providing
some tips and resources for you to use as you continue your Sequencer training in Unreal
Engine.
Here are a few tips we've covered before focusing on the Sequencer timeline tricks and notable
hotkeys.
Now, I used some of these in the previous course videos, so please try them out and
see which ones work best for your workflows.
Here are a few additional notable shortcuts for Sequencer.
And as usual, the 2014 Fortnite Whitepaper is still a valuable resource, providing insight
into the Epic Games cinematic process.
Feel free to follow the link and download the paper.
Once again, I would highly recommend that if you want to learn more, our online documentation
has a robust section for cinematics and Sequencer available for free online, as there is even
more that can be done in Sequencer than I could possibly cover in these course sessions.
Finally, all the online resources and links to some of the tools discussed today can be
found by following the URLs on this slide.
Feel free to pause here or take a screenshot for later reference.
That's it for the Sequencer Animation Production Workflows course.
I want to thank you for spending your time with me, and I hope that these videos were
helpful as you continue working with Sequencer in Unreal Engine.